you buy all the products you put them on
your face and then your skin gets worse
rude today we're busting five skincare
myths that are ruining your skin and i
swear we are not just going to talk
about wearing sunscreen every day myth
number one high concentrations are
better it makes sense that we feel this
way if five percent of something is good
then ten percent must be twice as good
but there's diminishing returns when it
comes to skin care it's like eating
burgers one burger is good two burgers
is maybe better but then ten burgers oh
you start to feel like trash or cake
ingredients one teaspoon of vanilla
extract is nice two is better the whole
bottle maybe a bit much and if the whole
cake is made of vanilla extract it's
trash same with actives it's about
hitting that sweet spot if you don't
have enough of something it has no
effect if you have too much of something
then it's too much you're in side effect
territory for skincare this is usually
irritation or stripping your skin
barrier you know you've done this if
your normal products or maybe even water
start to sting when they get on your
face your skin might go red and feel
tight it might be weirdly shiny you
might also get bumpy which is sort of
the opposite of what you are going for
irritating your skin also leads to
inflammation and inflammation is also
not good there's this term inflammation
that some brands have been trying to
make catch on for a while now it hasn't
really but the gist is inflammation can
speed up some of those changes that
happen in your skin over time not good
inflammation is also one of the four
factors that contributes to acne so
stick with a concentration that makes
your skin happy don't try to go higher
just for the sake of going higher and if
it says to start on a low percentage
start at a low percentage don't try to
cut corners myth number two you should
exfoliate flaky skin this also seems
like it should make sense your skin
wants to come off so you help it off
with exfoliants but sometimes the reason
skin is flaking off is because your
skin's natural shedding processes are
messed up and adding exfoliants will
probably mess it up more if your flaky
skin is red or irritated then adding an
irritating exfoliant into the mix is not
going to help so if that's your
situation leave it alone let it chill
maybe slather on a nice soothing cream
like la roche-posay's sicker plus balm
or even just vaseline lack of hydration
can also sometimes mess up your skin's
desk formation descrimation is the fancy
name for your skin's natural exfoliation
process okay sometimes you do need to
get rid of dead skin flakes really
quickly like if you're about to put on
foundation in that case you can
exfoliate it off super gently with a
damp towel or a gentle peeling gel just
to break off the dead skin at the
surface but apart from that leave it
alone myth number three using every
active ingredient every day this happens
a lot you have a day routine and a night
routine but you want to use 10 products
so you use 3 in the morning 7 at night
now some people enjoy having a nice long
routine but you probably don't need one
and sometimes it is too much quite a lot
of actives are fine being used less
regularly than once a day you can use
them once or twice a week for example
there are studies on tretinoin which is
a vitamin a product where they're used
once every three days vitamin c is
believed to have a depot effect in other
words it stays in your skin and stays
working for more than 24 hours there's
also exfoliation it's usually
recommended that you only exfoliate once
maybe twice a week so you don't need to
use every product every day the best
approach is to learn to listen to your
skin and give it the products it needs
and not mess it up more when it's
already a bit messed up i talk more
about getting to know your skin in my
ebook the lab muffin guide to basic
skincare but basically you want to keep
track of what you're putting on your
skin and how your skin responds keeping
a skincare diary is a good way taking
photos is also good you should also
change one thing at a time so you can
see how your skin actually responds and
remember if you use too much you can get
irritation you can mess up your skin
barrier and get that textured
uncomfortable type feeling and that
sting that inflammation can also lead to
accelerated aging and acne i personally
use a three night cycle on night one
i'll use a retinoid on night two i'll
use a chemical exfoliant and then on
night 3 it's the rest night where i use
gentler things like niacinamide and
vitamin c for me vitamin c is quite
gentle but for some people it's not so
again listening to your skin is super
important myth number four cleanser
doesn't matter because you're washing it
off your skin sorting out my cleanser
and my cleansing routine was one of the
things that made the biggest changes to
my skin there's actually quite a lot of
scientific research on cleanses like how
to make them more gentle how to make
sure they're not contributing to acne
but there's still a lot of cleansers on
the market that don't follow the rules
for example cleanses should have a low
ph and contain some hydrating
ingredients to stop from stripping your
skin make sure you look up reviews from
people with similar skin to you before
you buy a cleanser i actually did a
couple of videos on cleansing myths a
while ago and i think i forgot this myth
i have oily skin so when i was younger i
used a pretty harsh cleanser i used it
twice a day and it dried out my skin but
then what happened was it felt like my
skin was really tight and hard and the
oil just sat on top and after i cleansed
in the morning and then put on makeup
the oil came back really fast and messed
up my makeup once i got better at skin
care i switched to a gentle cleanser
once a day and my skin has been so much
happier makeup lasts for much longer it
doesn't sort of flood back with oil as
quickly also if you're wearing a mask a
lot you might end up with skin issues
from that wearing a mask means you're
trapping moisture against your skin and
that extra moisture changes the microbes
on your skin and also makes your barry a
bit more permeable there's also that
extra friction and there's just a lot of
irritation and inflammation going on
there taking off your mask when it's
safe and cleansing underneath is a
really good idea if you're out you can
use wipes or micellar water also check
for how you're cleansing as well so
check your water temperature and also
what cleansing tools you're using myth 5
sunscreens are all awful i kind of lied
but i see a lot of people trying to make
the wrong sunscreen work i don't mean in
terms of chemical sunscreen or physical
sunscreen or what spf but just what
works for you and so many sunscreens are
just annoying they might roll off your
skin they might break you out they might
just feel really terrible i blame men
there are a lot of white dudes in the
skincare industry who don't use skincare
they use shampoo on their face and
they're making decisions about what
products we get and so this crappy
sunscreen situation means a lot of us
aren't using enough sunscreen or we
might just skip sunscreen altogether but
there are more women and men who use
skincare or they're just good at
listening to what their customers
actually want they're more considerate
are getting into decision-making roles
and so there are a lot of better
sunscreens hitting the market so don't
feel like you just have to put up with
bad sunscreens not all sunscreens are
awful a lot of them feel really nice on
your skin and a lot of fear-mongering
about sunscreen ingredients and rules
for what sunscreen you're meant to use
aren't really legitimate anyway it's
more about finding a sunscreen that you
enjoy so you're happy to wear it every
day and you can apply a decent amount so
about a quarter teaspoon for your face
like and subscribe to promise to
yourself that you'll do better and let
me know the worst myth you believed in
the comments